harry elder i've always doubted if if
i had this doubt that california would
get to question two
to get to question two right now you
have a significant lead in the polls
my question is this do these polls hold
and if so why
well sean there's a reason that 45 000
people have contributed to my candidacy
we're going to have the actual
fundraising numbers later on uh put out
but 2.2 million people signed a petition
to have this man recalled
we're talking about 25 of them at least
independents and democrats
who just voted for him two years earlier
so it's awfully hard to characterize
this as some sort of republican takeover
and 53 percent of people say that they
don't want gavin newsom to have
a second term uh and it's because of the
crime
because the rising homelessness because
of the outrageous way he shut down
this state in the more most draconian
way than any of the other 50 states
while sitting up there at that french
laundry restaurant
with the very people that drafted the
mandates not wearing masks
not socially distancing but telling
everybody else to do just that
and then you have the outrageous cost of
living the average price of a home in
california because of the
environmental extremists that he doesn't
want to stand down cost 150
more than the average price of a home uh
in in the united states
you add it all up this guy has got to go
and as you pointed out
more people now want him to go they want
him to stay and he's very
very nervous if andrew cuomo isn't he
sure is
well he certainly is and i mean i guess
while
putting you know draconian restrictions
on the people of california no in school
learning
but his kids had in school learning in a
private school
or pictures of his kids at a summer camp
while
everybody else had to mask up they had
no masks apparently
so i think people one too many examples
of just uh
utter elitism and hypocrisy
speaking of cuomo let me run the new
york post images
um i don't know larry maybe what do i
know i'm just a talk show host but
you know 11 women making serious
allegations against you
that a report from the attorney general
of new york says
is criminal both on the state level and
on the federal level
and there is today poolside with a young
aide
and they're there together
i don't think the optics are exactly
ideal
no they aren't and the optics out here
in california weren't ideal when he had
as you pointed out
gavin newsom's his own kids in summer
camp not wearing mass well just
momentarily he had suggested
that everybody else should be wearing
masks and you mentioned education
75 percent of black boys in california
i'm not making this up sean
cannot read at state levels of
proficiency and that was pre-pandemic
and the levels of proficiency aren't
very high nearly half of all third
graders cannot
and they lost a whole year of in-school
education while as you pointed out
his own kids were enjoying in-person
private education it is why one of the
many things i'm going to do if i'm
fortunate enough to be elected governor
is to push for choice the money should
follow the child rather than the other
way around
the polls show that black and brown
parents overwhelmingly want school
choice
and they keep pulling that lever for the
democratic party that's not giving it to
them i'm going to change that narrative
that's why i'm asking people to go to
elector.com
throw a little something in the tip jar
because he can raise an unlimited amount
of money i cannot i need help from other
people
elect elder.com elect elder.com i really
appreciate it
all right larry elder thanks for being
with us when we come back hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else